the length s arena in Cologne packed
with an audience of almost 15,000 and
millions more watching the event /
livestream the organizers say that makes
it the biggest counter-strike event in
the world I'm grants me the lines and
the fact that there are so many people
here shows that this isn't an issue vent
counter-strike is a computer game what's
known as a tactical shooter played by
different players at the same time or
taking an active role in the unfolding
drama no one here would call it a killer
game I think it's pure enjoyment I
rather watch counter-strike instead of
playing it so I think I think for me
personally it's worth it Ulrich schulter
takes us behind the stage to the warm-up
area where we're supposed to meet some
of the professional players but there's
no one here okay no yeah she does have
you know staff the players are
definitely stars if you see the way
people cheer them when they come on
stage and endless lines of people
waiting for autographs before z10 he
thought since he can come
Fabian Kirishima PA from a team called
faze clan signing autographs is routine
for the 21 year old Frenchman it's part
of my work it's necessary for the job
but we are making the feds 16 teams from
Europe the USA and brazil are battling
it out in Cologne schulter is meeting
with representatives of a Swedish media
company looking to expand its operations
I believe the market is worth around 900
million euros and we're looking at
thirty to forty percent annual growth so
this will be worth billions pretty
quickly and that means it's lucrative
for the players to fighting for
million-dollar prizes